à quand les liaisons dangereuses lui par
jean paul gaultier
le couturier qui a toutes les odeurs ce
même celle de choisir des mannequins qui
ne sont plus des jeunes filles en fleur
il vient de dévoiler sa collection
d'hiver yauba grégoire était là mais non
c'est pas son défilé un spectacle qu'il
règle comme un chef d'orchestre
tout le monde veut tu y être c'est le
must le défilé auquel on doit assister
jean paul gaultier on hamelin des tasses
mais on vient
ne serait ce que pour le délire côté
letton spectaculaire qui peut attendre
qui peut paraître provocateur et
agressif mais en vérité ce sont ces
mêmes vêtements que je présente d'une
certaine façon la foire après dans les
boutiques et ils sont portables
puisqu'on les portes
il est le deuxième dans le peloton des
créateurs qui vend le plus 500 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les américains en parle comme d'un
phénomène dans le défilé une journaliste
un homme travesti sa cousine je suis dit
qu'en fin de compte y avait pas que le
type mannequin l'archétype du mannequin
traditionnelles qui étaient bien et
aussi d'autres formes de beauté j'essaye
de les montrer c'est en fin de compte
crois que sur toucher à ces prêts en fin
de compte de ce qui se passe dans la rue
et c'est ce que je ferais si l'on fait
un peu les vêtements soient portées
c'est la rue qui m'intéresse c'est la
vie en plein conte avec man dans un
musée ou un vêtement sur un simple c'est
la mort vaultier fait ça pour rire mais
pas du tout il a sens de l'humour jeu
aucun sens de l'humour
quatre mille personnes sous la halle de
la villette on ne se précipite pas pour
rien il ne s'amuse peut-être pas mais
nous oui
j'ai aucun sens et demi chez quelqu'un
de sinistrés ennuyeux non c'est
quelqu'un de très travail
pas facile à porter surtout à l'antenne